Have you ever wondered why, supposedly, people
used to think the Moon was made out of cheese?
Well, wonder no more.
It’s because it was formed in the Milky
Way… (maybe include sound effects?
http://instantrimshot.com/classic/?sound=rimshot
and *crickets*) :-)
In fact, nobody really ever thought the Moon
was made of green cheese…
Well, there are nutters out there, so it’s
possible that there was at least one person
who thought the Moon was made of cheese, and
kids used to sometimes believe the Moon was
made of cheese thanks to various fables, but
kids will believe anything.
For instance, in 1902 it was found that the
most common theory as to what the Moon was
made of according to children in the United
States was that it was made of cheese.
But these children weren’t exactly setting
the bar high as other popular responses from
them were things like “yellow paper, dead
people, and rags.”
So other than lunatics and children who were
told so by their parents via fables, nobody
seriously ever thought the Moon was made of
cheese.
Another common misconception surrounding the
Moon/green cheese thing is that the “green”
here is referring to the color green.
While there are actually green cheeses, what
the “green” signifies here is “new”
or “fresh”, so “the Moon is made of
new cheese.”
This was a common way to refer to cheese where
the whey either hadn’t yet all been pressed
out or had just been removed from the curds,
in other words, cheese that has not been aged
at all.
So how did this “Moon is made of green cheese”
thing all start and become popularized?
It isn’t entirely clear who was the first
to come up with the expression, but it became
extremely common starting in the mid-16th
century.
The credit for the person to come up with
the expression usually goes to famed French
monk and scholar François Rabelais or English
writer John Heywood.
Heywood first used it in The Proverbs of John
Heywood written in 1546
“Ye fetch circumquaques to make me believe,
Or thinke, that the moone is made of greene
cheese.
And when ye have made me a lout in all these,
It seemeth ye would make me goe to bed at
noone.”
So basically, the expression itself simply
was used to refer to something so ludicrous
that only the extremely gullible would believe
it.
Another early example using the statement
in the same way can be found in 1565 in Shacklock’s
Hatched of Heresies:
“Whilst they tell for truthe Luther his
lowde lyes, so that they may make theyr blinde
brotherhode and the ignorant sort beleve that
the mone is made of grene chese”
Yet another early reference from John Wilkins’
New World Book 1 (1638), which is explicitly
clear as to the meaning of the expression
and that it had become common,
“You may as soon persuade some Country Peasants
that the Moon is made of Green Cheese (as
we say) as that ’tis bigger than his Cart-wheel”
While in the early days it was used just to
signify gullibility, in the last couple centuries
many started thinking that people actually
used to believe this, which is kind of ironic
if you think about it.
This is not unlike how people started believing
that most thought the world was flat during
the Middle Ages, when in truth in many parts
of the world people have known the world wasn’t
flat for well over 2000 years.
For instance, Eratosthenes (at the time the
head librarian at the library of Alexandria)
around 240 BC not only knew the Earth was
round, as most Greek scholars did at the time,
but managed to become the first known person
to calculate the circumference of the Earth
accurately, only off by about 2%.
He also calculated the distance from the Earth
to the Sun and was off by only about a half
a percent.
Not only that, but he calculated the tilt
of the Earth on its axis and was off by less
than half a degree.
Another amazing accomplishment by Eratosthenes
was that he basically invented the discipline
of Geography with his remarkable three book
treaties Geographikia.
Bonus Moon Facts:
• Yet another Moon myth is that during the
1950s and 1960s, Americans were all crazy
about getting to the Moon.
In fact, according to Smithsonian space historian
Roger Launius, during the early days of the
Apollo program, the U.S. space program was
one of the top government programs Americans
listed that they thought should be dropped,
with a full 60% of Americans feeling that
the U.S. was spending too much money on space
flight.
• Contrary to popular belief, there is no
“dark side of the Moon”.
The Moon has days and nights, just like Earth.
One Moon “day” is 29 1/2 Earth days.
This rotation coincides perfectly with its
rotation around the Earth so that we always
only see one side of the Moon.
• NASA claimed in 2002 the Moon was made
out of cheese after discovering an expiration
date printed on the Moon.
They released the following statement, “Using
the new camera on the recently refitted Hubble
Space Telescope, astronomers have been able
to confirm that the Moon is made of green
cheese.
The telling clue was the resolution of a numeric
date after which the Moon may go bad.
Controversy still exists, however, over whether
the date resolved is truly an expiration date
or just a ‘sell by’ date.”
This, of course, was posted by NASA on April
1st…
• While there is still some debate on how
exactly the Moon formed, one of the most popular
theories is that the Moon formed from a collision
between the Earth and a planet-sized object
about 4.6 billion years ago, called the “Big
Whack”.
When the impact happened, a cloud of vaporized
rock shot off the Earth’s surface and went
into orbit around the Earth.
Over time, the cloud cooled and condensed
into a ring of small, solid objects which
then slowly gathered together, eventually
forming the Moon.
• The largest crater on the Moon is about
550 miles in diameter and is near the South
Pole-Aitken Basin.
The impact caused by the asteroid that formed
this crater was almost powerful enough to
split the Moon into pieces.
• The Moon used to have very active volcanoes.
The dark areas of the Moon, called maria (meaning
“seas”), are cratered landscapes that
were flooded with lava, which then froze forming
smooth rock areas that resemble, from a distance,
bodies of water on Earth.
• The Moon has a surface area of about 14.6
million square miles, which is about 92.6%
less surface area than the Earth has.
This is about 4 times the surface area of
the United States.
• Jack Schmitt, an Apollo 17 astronaut,
has the distinction of being the first known
human to have extraterrestrial hay fever.
After returning to the lunar module and taking
his helmet off, he had an instant reaction
to the Moon dust with his nose stuffing up
quickly.
This lasted a couple hours before going away.
According to Schmitt, he wasn’t the only
one to experience this, but pilots don’t
like to admit to any adverse symptoms or they
think they’ll be grounded.
If you’re curious, several astronauts say
that fresh Moon dust smells like spent gunpowder.
• Another slightly popular “Moon myth”
is that people can go temporarily crazy and/or
that more criminal acts occur during full
moons.
There have been numerous studies done to try
to see if there is actually a link between
the phases of the Moon and mental illness
and the like, but, not surprisingly, to date
nobody’s been able to find any such connection.
Nevertheless, the word “lunatic” ultimately
comes from the Latin for “moon”, “luna”,
via the Old French “lunatique”, meaning
“insane”.
It first popped up in English around the 13th
century and referenced the mistaken belief
that the Moon can make people crazy.
• In 2002, a 72 year old Buzz Aldrin punched
Bart Sibrel who is a “we never landed on
the moon” conspiracy theorist, “documentary”
maker, and cab driver.
Sibrel invited Aldrin to a hotel with Sibrel
telling him he was making a children’s TV
show on space.
Once Aldrin arrived at the hotel, Sibrel pulled
out a Bible and tried to get Aldrin to put
his hand on it and swear that he had walked
on the Moon.
Needless to say, Aldrin was pretty irritated
at this point.
Things got worse when Sibrel called Aldrin
a “liar” and a “coward”, at which
point Aldrin punched him.
Lucky he didn’t also call him a poltroon,
or Aldrin may have pulled a “President Andrew
Jackson”, who once killed a man for calling
Jackson a “scoundrel, poltroon, and a coward”
in the newspaper.
• In 2009, Sibrel found himself in hot water
once again while working as a cab driver.
Sibrel wanted a woman’s parking spot, but
she refused to pull out of it, at which point
Sibrel was able to park across from the woman.
After parking, he proceeded to get out of
his cab, hop onto the hood of the woman’s
car, and jump up and down causing $1,400 worth
of damage to the car.